Chris Anderson : Bienvenue à TED.
Richard Branson : Merci beaucoup. Le premier TED a été génial.
CA : Avez-vous rencontré des gens intéressants ?
RB : Ce qui est bien à TED, c'est que tout le monde est intéressant.
J'ai été heureux de voir Goldie Hawn,
parce que je voulais m'excuser auprès d'elle.
J'ai dîner avec elle il y a environ deux ans et j'ai -
elle avait une grosse alliance, je l'ai mise à mon doigt et je ne pouvais plus l'enlever.
Quand je suis ensuite rentré à la maison,
ma femme voulait savoir pourquoi j'avais la grosse -
l'énorme alliance d'une autre femme à mon doigt.
Et, quoiqu'il en soit, le lendemain nous avons dû aller chez le joaillier
et la faire couper.
Alors, (rires)
alors, toutes mes excuses à Goldie.
CA : Elle est bien bonne.
Donc nous allons montrer quelques diapositives
d'une de vos - quelques-unes de vos sociétés.
Vous en avez commencé une ou deux à votre époque.
Virgin Atlantic, Virgin Records...
je suppose que tout a commencé avec un magazine intitulé "Student".
Et puis, oui, celles-là aussi. Ma question est : comment faites-vous ?
RB : J'ai lu toutes les consignes TED --
vous ne devez pas parler de votre propre business, etc,
maintenant vous me le demandez.
Alors, je suppose que vous n'allez pas pouvoir me jeter de la scène
puisque vous avez posé la question.
(Rires)
CA : Cela dépend quand même de la réponse.
RB : Je crois que j'ai appris tôt que si vous savez diriger une entreprise,
vous savez diriger n'importe quelle entreprise.
Une entreprise, c'est trouver les bonnes personnes,
les inspirer, en tirer le meilleur;
j'adore apprendre et je suis incroyablement curieux,
j'aime remettre en cause le statu quo
et essayer de le chambouler.
J'ai donc vu la vie comme un long processus d'apprentissage.
Et si je vois - si je vole sur la compagnie aérienne de quelqu'un d'autre
et je trouve que l'expérience n'est pas agréable, ce qu'elle n'était pas en -
il y a 21 ans, alors je vais penser que, peut-être, je peux créer
le type de compagnie aérienne sur laquelle j'aimerais voler.
Donc j'ai pris un 747 d'occasion de Boeing et fait un test.
CA : Eh bien, c'était quelque chose de bizarre,
parce que vous avez fait cette action que beaucoup de gens considéraient folle.
En fait, dans un certain sens, cela a failli ruiner votre empire à un moment donné.
J'ai eu une conversation avec un des banquiers d'investissement qui,
au moment où vous avez vendu Virgin Records
et investi massivement dans Virgin Atlantic,
sa vision était que vous échangiez
la quatrième plus grande entreprise mondiale de disques
pour la 25ème compagnie aérienne mondiale et que vous étiez fou.
Pourquoi avez-vous fait cela ?
RB : Bien, je pense qu'il a une très petite ligne de partage entre la réussite et l'échec.
Je pense qui si vous démarrez un business sans soutien financier,
vous allez vraisemblablement aller du mauvais côté de cette ligne de partage.
Nous avions - nous étions attaqués par British Airways ;
ils essayaient de ruiner notre compagnie aérienne,
et ils ont lancé ce qui a été appelé la campagne des mauvais coups.
J'ai compris que tout l'empire allait vraisemblablement s'effondrer
si je n'y mettais pas d'argent.
Pour protéger les postes des gens qui travaillaient pour la compagnie aérienne,
et protéger les postes des gens qui travaillaient pour la société de disques,
je devais vendre les bijoux de famille pour protéger la compagnie aérienne.
CA : Après Napster, vous apparaissez en fait comme un génie
à cause de ça, aussi.
RB : Ouais, ça s'est trouvé être la bonne décision.
Mais, ouais, c'était triste sur le moment, mais nous avons continué.
CA : Maintenant vous utilisez beaucoup la marque Virgin
et il semble que cela génère de la synergie d'une affaire à l'autre.
Quelle est la position de la marque dans votre esprit ?
RB : Bien, j'aime à penser qu'elle se positionne en synonyme de qualité,
que, si quelqu'un passe à côté d'une société Virgin, il...
CA : Elle est de qualité, Richard, voyons maintenant, tout le monde dit la qualité -- l'esprit ?
RB : Non, mais j'allais en venir à ceci.
Nous nous amusons beaucoup et je pense que les personnes qui y travaillent l'apprécient.
Nous, nous -- comme je le dis, nous entrons et nous secouons les autres industries
et je pense que nous le faisons différemment
et je pense que les industries ne sont plus les mêmes
dès que Virgin attaque un marché.
CA : Mais il y a eu quelques-uns de vos lancements qui -
où la marque n'a peut-être pas marché aussi bien.
Par exemple, Virgin Mariages - qu'est-ce que c'était ?
(Rires)
RB : Nous n'avons pas trouvé de clients.
(Applaudissements)
CA : En fait j'étais aussi curieux pourquoi -
je pense que vous avez raté une occasion avec votre marque de préservatifs, appelés "Copains".
Ne pouviez-vous pas utiliser la marque Virgin pour ça aussi ?
"Ne soyez plus vierge (virgin en anglais)", ou quelque chose comme ça.
RB : De nouveau, nous aurions eu des problèmes pour trouver des clients.
Nous avons - souvent quand vous lancez une entreprise et vous avez des réclamations de consommateurs
vous savez les traiter.
Mais environ trois mois après le lancement de la société de préservatifs
j'ai eu une lettre, une réclamation,
je me suis assis et j'ai répondu par une longue lettre à cette dame en m'excusant platement.
Mais manifestement il n'y avait pas grand-chose que je puisse faire.
Puis six mois après, ou neuf mois après que le problème a eu lieu
j'ai reçu cette ravissante lettre avec une photo du bébé
me demandant si je voulais devenir le parrain, ce que je suis devenu.
Donc, tout s'est bien terminé.
CA : Vraiment ? Vous auriez dû apporter une photo. C'est merveilleux.
RB : J'aurais dû.
CA : Maintenant donnez-nous quelques chiffres.
Quelles sont les valeurs ?
Quelle est la taille du groupe au total ?
Combien - quel est le chiffre d'affaires total ?
RB : C'est environ 25 milliards de dollars au total.
CA : Et combien d'employés ?
RB : Environ 55.000.
CA : Donc vous avez été photographié de plusieurs manières à des moments différents
et n'avez jamais été soucieux de préserver votre dignité ou quoique ce soit d'autre.
Qu'est-ce que c'est que ça ? Était-ce truqué ?
RB : Non. Nous lancions un mégastore à Los Angeles, je crois.
Non, je veux dire, je crois -
CA : Mais, ce sont vos cheveux ?
RB : Non.
CA : C'était quoi, celle-là ?
RB : Descente surprise pour le thé.
CA : OK.
(Rires)
CA : Ah, c'était plutôt marrant. C'était une magnifique voiture bateau dans laquelle -
RB : Oh, cette voiture que nous - en fait nous, nous -
c'était un événement TED, je pense.
Est-ce que - pouvez-vous faire une pause sur celle-là une minute ?
(Rires)
RB : C'est un boulot difficile, n'est-ce pas ?
CA : Je veux dire - c'est un boulot difficile.
(Rires)
Quand je suis arrivé en Amérique j'ai voulu aussi essayer avec les employées
et elles ont - ils ont des règles différentes là-bas,
c'est très bizarre.
RB : Je sais, j'ai des avocats qui disent que je ne dois pas faire des choses comme ça, mais -
CA : A ce sujet, dites-nous -
RB : Nous avons lancé Pammy (Pamela Anderson), vous savez,
pensant à tort que nous pouvions nous frotter à Coca-Cola,
et nous avons lancé une bouteille de cola nommée "The Pammy"
ayant, un peu, les formes de Pamela Anderson.
Mais le problème c'est qu'elle n'arrêtait pas de se renverser, mais -
(Rires)
CA : Dessinée par Philippe Starck, peut-être ?
RB : Bien sûr.
CA : Donc nous allons passer ici quelques photos supplémentaires. Virgin Mariages. Très joli.
Et, OK, arrêtez là. C'était - vous avez obtenu une récompense, je pense ?
RB : Ouais, bien, 25 ans auparavant nous avons lancé le titre des Sex Pistols
"God Save The Queen", et je n'aurais jamais supposé
que 25 ans après elle allait vraiment nous anoblir.
Mais d'une certaine manière, elle doit avoir une mémoire défaillante, je pense.
CA : Eh bien, Dieu l'a sauvée et vous avez eu votre juste récompense.
Vous aimez qu'on vous appelle Sir Richard, ou comment ?
RB : Personne ne m'a jamais appelé Sir Richard.
De temps en temps en Amérique, j'entends des gens dire Sir Richard
et je pense qu'il y a une pièce de Shakespeare se jouant quelque part.
Mais nulle part ailleurs autrement.
CA : OK. Pouvez-vous donc utiliser votre titre pour quoi que que ce soit ou est-ce seulement...
RB : Non. Je suppose que si vous avez des problèmes
pour avoir une réservation dans un restaurant ou autre,
ça peut valoir la peine de l'utiliser.
CA : Genre, ce n'est pas "Richard Branson", c'est "Sir Richard Branson".
RB : Je vais habituer la secrétaire à l'utiliser.
CA : OK. Alors, regardons l'espace.
Je pense, avec nous, nous avons une vidéo qui montre ce que vous manigancez
et Virgin Galactic dans les airs.
Donc c'est le vaisseau spatial dessiné par Bert Rutan ?
RB : Ouais, il va être prêt dans -- prêt dans 12 mois
et puis nous allons faire des tests poussés pendant 12 mois
et dans 24 mois à partir d'aujourd'hui
les gens pourront faire un tour dans l'espace.
CA : L'intérieur a été dessiné par Philippe Starck ?
RB : Philippe a fait le - ouais, une bonne part -
des logos et il construit la station spatiale au Nouveau Mexique,
et fondamentalement il a juste jeté un œil
et la station spatiale sera un œil géant,
quand vous serez dans l'espace
vous devriez pouvoir voir cet énorme œil qui vous regarde.
Quand vous atterrirez, vous allez pouvoir revenir à cet œil géant.
Mais c'est un génie absolu en design.
CA : Mais vous ne lui avez pas demandé de dessiner le moteur ?
RB : Philippe est plutôt fantasque,
alors je pense qu'il ne serait pas la meilleure personne pour dessiner le moteur, non.
CA : Il a donné une conférence merveilleuse ici, il a deux jours.
RB : Ouais ? Non, il est un...
CA : Eh bien, quelques personnes l'ont trouvée merveilleuse,
d'autres personnes l'ont trouvée complètement bizarre.
Mais, personnellement, je l'ai trouvée merveilleuse.
RB : C'est un merveilleux enthousiaste, et c'est pourquoi je l'aime. Mais -
CA : Vous avez toujours eu ce virus de l'exploration en vous.
L'avez-vous jamais regretté ?
RB : Plusieurs fois.
Je pense que les expéditions en ballon et en bateau que nous avons faites dans le passé -
j'ai été sorti de la mer six fois par hélicoptère, alors -
à chaque fois, je ne pensais pas pouvoir rentrer pour le raconter.
Alors à ces moments
vous vous posez vraiment la question de ce que vous faites là ou ...
CA : Quand avez-vous été le plus de -
quand vous avez pensé, ça y est, je vais y passer ?
RB : Je pense que les aventures en ballon ont été - chacune a été -
à chacune, en fait, je pense que nous nous en sommes approchés.
Et, tout d'abord nous -
personne n'avait en fait traversé l'Atlantique dans une montgolfière avant,
alors nous avons dû construire cette montgolfière qui serait capable de voler dans le jet-stream,
et nous n'étions pas tout à fait sûrs,
quand un ballon rentre effectivement dans le jet-stream,
s'il allait vraiment survivre aux vents à 350 km/h qui s'y trouvent.
Donc au premier décollage de Sugarloaf pour traverser l'Atlantique,
comme nous avancions dans le jet-stream, cet énorme ballon -
le haut du ballon a fini par voler à quelques 350 km/h,
et la capsule dans laquelle nous étions en bas, allait peut-être à 4 km/h,
puis a décollé.
C'était comme de tenir un millier de chevaux.
Nous croisions les doigts,
priant que le ballon reste entier, ce qui, heureusement, est arrivé.
Mais les fins de chaque voyage à ballon, étaient --
quelque chose semblait mal se passer chaque fois,
et cette fois-là particulièrement, l'aéronaute plus expérimenté qui était avec moi,
a sauté et m'a laissé m'agripper de toutes mes forces à la vie.
(Rires)
CA : Vous a-t-il dit de sauter, ou a-t-il juste dit : "Je m'en vais !" et...
RB : Non, il m'a dit de sauter, mais une fois son poids enlevé,
le ballon a grimpé à 12.000 pieds et je...
CA : Vous avez inspiré un roman à Ian McEwan avec cette histoire.
RB : Ouais. Non, j'ai mis mon masque à oxygène et je me suis tenu au sommet du ballon,
avec mon parachute, regardant les nuages tourbillonnant en dessous,
essayant de trouver le courage pour sauter dans la Mer du Nord, ce qui -
c'était un moment de très, très, très grande solitude.
Mais, quoi qu'il en soit, nous avons réussi à survivre.
CA : Avez-vous sauté ou - est-il descendu à la fin ?
RB : Je savais qu'il me restait environ une demi-heure de carburant,
et je savais que si je sautais,
je n'aurais que quelques minutes à vivre.
Alors je suis revenu dans la capsule et essayé désespérément
de m'assurer que je faisais le bon choix.
J'ai écrit quelques mots à ma famille. J'ai grimpé de nouveau,
regardé de nouveau ces nuages,
je suis retourné dans la capsule de nouveau.
Finalement j'ai juste pensé : il y a un meilleur moyen.
J'ai cet énorme ballon au-dessus de moi,
c'est le plus grand parachute possible, pourquoi ne pas l'utiliser ?
Je me suis débrouillé pour faire descendre le ballon à travers les nuages
et à environ 15 mètres, avant de toucher la mer, je me suis jeté par-dessus bord.
Le ballon a touché la mer
et a rebondi à 3000 mètres, sans moi.
Mais c'était une sensation merveilleuse d'être dans cette eau et -
CA : Qu'avez-vous écrit à votre famille ?
RB : Juste ce que vous feriez dans une situation comme celle-là,
juste "je vous aime beaucoup et" -
Je leur avais déjà écrit une lettre avant de partir pour ce voyage, qui -
juste au cas où il se passerait quoique que ce soit.
Mais heureusement ils n'ont jamais eu à l'utiliser.
CA : Vos entreprises ont bénéficié des retombées médiatiques incroyables grâce à ces exploits.
Les années - et jusqu'à ce que j'arrête de regarder les sondages,
vous étiez regardé comme une sorte de héros au Royaume-Uni et ailleurs.
Les cyniques pourraient dire : "c'est juste un type astucieux pour le business
faisant ce qu'il faut pour réaliser son style particulier de marketing."
Quelle a été la retombée médiatique de ceci ?
RB : Évidemment les experts en relations publiques disent qu'en tant que propriétaire d'une compagnie aérienne,
la dernière chose que vous devriez faire c'est d'aller en ballon et en bateau,
et de vous écraser en mer.
(Rires)
CA : Ils n'ont pas tort, Richard.
RB : En fait, je crois que notre compagnie aérienne a acheté une pleine page de publicité à ce moment-là disant,
"allez, Richard,
il y a de meilleur moyens pour traverser l'Atlantique".
(Rires)
CA : Pour faire tout cela,
vous avez dû être un génie dès le début, n'est-ce pas ?
RB : Je ne vais pas vous contredire.
(Rires)
CA : OK, ce n'était pas une question difficile, OK.
CA : Ne - n'étiez-vous pas mauvais en classe ?
RB : J'étais dyslexique, je n'avais aucune compréhension du travail de classe.
J'aurais certainement raté les tests de QI
C'est une des raisons pour laquelle j'ai quitté l'école à 15 ans.
Et si je ne suis pas intéressé par quelque chose, je ne le comprends pas.
En tant que dyslexique,
on se retrouve quelquefois dans des situations étranges.
Par exemple, j'ai dû --
j'ai dirigé le plus grand groupe d'entreprises privées en Europe,
mais j'ai été incapable de connaître la différence entre le net et le brut.
Les conseils d'administration ont été fascinants.
(Rires)
C'était plutôt bonnes nouvelles ou mauvaises nouvelles ?
Et d'habitude les gens disaient, "oh, et bien ce sont de mauvaises nouvelles".
CA : Mais juste pour clarifier, les 25 milliards bruts, n'est-ce pas, c'est brut ?
(Rires)
RB : Bien, j'espère que c'est net en fait, ayant -
J'ai raison.
CA : Non, croyez-moi, c'est brut.
(Rires)
RB : Alors quand j'ai eu 50 ans, quelqu'un m'a emmené hors de la salle du conseil et m'a dit,
"Écoutez Richard, voici un - laissez-moi vous faire un dessin --
voici un filet ("net" en anglais) dans la mer,
et les poissons sont pêchés dans ce filet.
Ce sont les profits qu'il vous reste dans ce petit filet,
tout le reste a été mangé".
Et j'ai enfin tout compris.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
CA : Mais, à l'école - aussi bien qu'étant -
réussissant mal scolairement,
vous étiez aussi le capitaine de l'équipe de cricket et de football,
donc vous étiez un genre de -- vous étiez un leader naturel,
mais juste un peu un -- étiez-vous un rebelle à ce moment-là, ou comment ...
RB : Ouais, je pense que j'étais un peu franc-tireur et - mais je - et j'étais,
ouais, j'étais heureusement bon en sports
j'avais au moins une chose où je pouvais briller à l'école.
CA : Certaines choses bizarres vous sont arrivées plus tôt dans votre vie.
Il y a une histoire à propos de votre mère
qui vous aurait laissé dans un champ, à l'âge de 4 ans et disant "OK, rentre à pied à la maison".
Est-ce vraiment arrivé ?
RB : Elle était, vous savez,
elle pensait que nous devions nous tenir sur nos deux jambes par nous-mêmes très tôt.
Alors elle nous a fait des choses, pour lesquelles elle serait arrêtée aujourd'hui,
comme nous pousser hors de la voiture
en nous disant de trouver notre propre chemin jusque chez grand-mère,
à environ 8 km de distance.
Ou nous faire faire de merveilleuses longues balades à vélo.
Nous n'avions jamais le droit de regarder la télévision.
CA : Mais y a-t-il un risque là ?
Il y a beaucoup de gens ici qui ont de l'argent, et qui ont des enfants,
et qui ont ce dilemme à propos de leur éducation.
Regardez-vous la génération actuelle d'enfants à venir et pensez-vous
ils sont trop protégés, ils ne savent pas ce qu'ils possèdent,
nous allons élever une génération de privilégiés...
RB : Non, je pense que si vous élevez des enfants,
vous voulez juste les étouffer d'amour, de louanges et d'enthousiasme.
Donc je ne pense pas que vous pouvez gâter-pourrir trop vos enfants en réalité.
CA : Vous n'avez pas mal tourné, je dois dire, je suis -
Votre professeur principal vous a dit --
il vous a trouvé un genre d'énigme à votre école -
il vous a dit, vous allez soit être millionnaire, soit finir en prison,
et je ne suis pas sûr lequel ce sera.
Qu'est-ce qui est arrivé en premier ?
(Rires)
RB : Eh bien, j'ai fait les deux. Je pense que je suis d'abord allé en prison.
J'étais poursuivi pour deux lois plutôt anciennes au Royaume-Uni.
J'ai été poursuivi dans le cadre de la loi de 1889 sur les maladies vénériennes
et la loi de 1916 sur les Publicités Indécentes.
Pour le premier cas, pour avoir mentionné les mots "maladie vénérienne" en public, ce qui -
il existait un centre pour aider les jeunes gens qui avaient des problèmes.
Un des problèmes qu'avaient ces jeunes gens était les maladies vénériennes.
Il y a une vieille loi qui dit
que vous ne pouvez pas en fait mentionner les mots "maladie vénérienne" ou l'imprimer en public.
Alors la police est venue frapper à ma porte et nous a dit qu'ils allaient nous arrêter
si nous continuions de mentionner les mots "maladie vénérienne".
Nous l'avons changé en "maladies sociales",
et les gens venaient avec de l'acné et des taches,
mais personne ne venait plus avec une MST.
Alors nous avons de nouveau mis MST et rapidement été arrêtés.
Ensuite, "Never Mind the Bollocks, Here's the Sex Pistols,"
le mot "bollocks", la police a décidé qu'il était grossier et donc nous avons été arrêtés
pour l'utilisation du mot "bollocks" dans l'album des Sex Pistols.
John Mortimer, le dramaturge, nous a défendus.
Il m'a demandé si je pouvais trouver un expert linguistique
qui viendrait avec des définitions différentes du mot "bollocks".
J'ai donc appelé l'université de Nottingham,
et demandé à parler au professeur de linguistique.
Il a dit : "Écoutez, "bollocks" n'est pas un - n'a rien avoir avec les boules en quoi que ce soit.
C'est en fait un surnom donné aux prêtres au 18ème siècle".
(Rires)
Il a continué, "De plus, je suis un prêtre moi-même".
Je lui ai donc demandé : "Voudriez-vous venir témoigner à la cour ?"
Il a répondu qu'il en serait ravi. Et j'ai dit -
et il a dit, "Voudriez-vous que je vienne avec mon col romain ?"
J'ai dit, "Oui, ce serait - s'il vous plait..."
(Rires)
CA : C'est super.
RB : Donc notre témoin principal était - a argumenté que c'était en fait
"Tant pis pour le Prêtre, voici les Sex Pistols".
(Rires)
Le juge nous a jugés - à son grand regret, non coupables, donc -
CA : C'est scandaleux.
(Applaudissements)
Alors sérieusement, y a-t-il un côté sombre ?
Beaucoup de gens diraient qu'il est impossible
pour quelqu'un de concocter cette incroyable collection d'affaires
sans poignarder quelques personnes dans le dos,
faire des choses pas très jolies.
Vous avez été accusé d'être impitoyable.
Il y a eu une biographie déplaisante écrite sur vous par quelqu'un.
Y a-t-il une chose vraie ? Y a-t-il du vrai là-dedans ?
RB : En fait, je ne pense pas que le stéréotype
du businessman écrasant les gens pour arriver au sommet,
de manière générale, fonctionne.
Je pense que si vous traitez bien les gens,
les gens vont revenir et vont revenir pour plus encore.
Je pense que tout ce que vous avez dans la vie est votre réputation
et c'est un très petit monde.
Je pense qu'en fait le meilleur moyen
de devenir un hommes d'affaires renommé est de traiter avec les gens équitablement et justement,
et j'aime à penser que c'est ainsi que nous dirigeons Virgin.
CA : Qu'en est-il des gens qui vous aiment et qui vous voient dépenser -
vous êtes continuellement embarqué dans ces nouveaux projets,
mais on a l'impression que vous êtes adonné aux lancements de nouveaux trucs.
Vous êtes excité par une idée et, tadam !
Réfléchissez-vous à l'équilibre de votre vie ?
Quel est le sentiment de votre famille
chaque fois que vous entrez dans quelque chose de grand et de nouveau ?
RB : Je crois aussi qu'être un père est incroyablement important,
alors depuis que les enfants étaient très petits,
quand ils vont en vacances, je vais en vacances avec eux.
Donc nous passons à peu près trois mois ensemble.
Nous sommes alors très proches. Nous avons beaucoup de chance,
nous avons cette minuscule île dans les Caraïbes et nous pouvons -
donc je peux les emmener là et nous pouvons amener des amis,
et nous pouvons jouer ensemble,
mais je peux aussi rester connecté à ce qui se passe.
CA : Vous avez commencé à parler ces dernières années
sur ce terme : le capitalisme philanthropique.
Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
RB : Le capitalisme a prouvé être un système qui fonctionne.
Vous savez, l'alternative, le communisme, n'a pas fonctionné.
Mais le problème avec le capitalisme est
que la grande richesse finit dans les mains d'un petit nombre de personnes,
et par conséquent une grande responsabilité va avec cette richesse.
Je pense qu'il est important que des individus,
qui sont dans une position fortunée, ne finissent pas par se concurrencer
pour des bateaux et des voitures de plus en plus grands,
mais utilisent cet argent pour, soit créer de nouveaux emplois,
soit s'attaquer aux problèmes mondiaux.
CA : Quels sont les problèmes qui vous préoccupent le plus, auxquels vous faites le plus attention,
et sur lesquels vous voulez employer vos ressources ?
RB : Eh bien, il y a beaucoup de problèmes.
Le réchauffement climatique est certainement une menace énorme pour l'humanité
et nous mettons beaucoup de temps et d'énergie à :
A) essayer de trouver des carburants alternatifs,
et B) nous avons juste lancé ce prix, qui est vraiment un prix
dans le cas où nous n'aurions pas de réponse sur les carburants alternatifs,
dans le cas où nous n'arriverions pas à baisser les émissions de carbone
rapidement et dans le cas où nous dépasserions le point limite,
nous avons besoin d'encourager les gens à inventer une manière
d'extraire le carbone de l'atmosphère terrestre.
Et nous avons juste - il n'y avait réellement personne
travaillant là-dessus auparavant, alors nous avons voulu que les gens essayent de -
tous les meilleurs cerveaux du monde commencent à y réfléchir,
et aussi à essayer d'expulser le méthane
hors de l'atmosphère terrestre.
Actuellement nous avons à peu près 15.000 personnes qui ont rempli les formulaires
disant qu'ils voulaient essayer.
Nous n'en avons besoin que d'une seule, donc nous avons de l'espoir.
CA : Vous travaillez aussi en Afrique sur quelques projets ?
RB : Oui, nous avons mis en place quelque chose appelé
la chambre de guerre, qui est peut être un terme inadéquat -
nous essayons de - peut-être que nous allons le changer - mais quoiqu'il en soit, c'est une chambre de guerre
pour essayer de coordonner toutes les attaques qui arrivent en Afrique,
et tous les problèmes sociaux en Afrique
et essayer de trouver les meilleures pratiques.
Alors, par exemple,
il y a un docteur en Afrique qui a trouvé que
donner des médicaments anti-rétroviraux à une femme enceinte de 24 semaines,
évite que le bébé ne soit infecté par le virus VIH quand il naît.
Donc en diffusant cette information à -
dans toute l'Afrique est important.
CA : La "chambre de guerre" résonne, cela sonne puissant et dramatique.
Y a-t-il un risque que le genre de business dont les héros occidentaux
sont tellement friands - ils sont habitués à avoir une idée,
faire réaliser la chose, et ils croient fortement
en leur capacité à faire une différence dans le monde.
Y a-t-il un risque que nous allions dans des endroits comme l'Afrique et disions
nous devons résoudre ce problème et nous pouvons le faire,
j'ai tous ces milliards de dollars, etc. -
voici ce qu'il faut faire. Et nous tombons sur une situation beaucoup plus complexe
et finissons par, en fait, mettre le désordre. Vous en inquiétez-vous ?
RB : Bien, tout d'abord sur cette situation particulière, nous sommes en fait -
nous y travaillons avec le gouvernement.
Thabo Mbeki a eu du mal à accepter
que le VIH et le SIDA étaient reliés, mais c'est un moyen,
pour lui de s'attaquer au problème et, au lieu de le critiquer mondialement,
c'est un moyen de travailler avec lui, avec son gouvernement.
C'est important que si les gens vont en Afrique et essayent d'aider,
ils n'aillent pas là-bas seulement quelques années puis repartent.
Ce doit être dans la durée.
Mais je pense que les leaders des affaires peuvent apporter leur savoir-faire entrepreneurial
et aider les gouvernements à approcher les choses légèrement différemment.
Par exemple, nous installons des cliniques en Afrique
où nous allons donner
des médicaments anti-rétroviraux, des traitements anti-tuberculeux gratuits
et des traitements anti-malaria gratuits.
Mais nous essayons d'en faire également des cliniques auto-suffisantes
de manière à ce que les gens payent pour d'autres aspects.
CA : Je veux dire que beaucoup de cyniques disent à votre sujet ou à celui de Bill Gates
ou qui que ce soit, que c'est vraiment être - c'est presque entraîné par
une sorte de désir, à nouveau, pour la bonne image,
pour éviter la culpabilité et pas comme un vrai instinct philanthropique.
Que leur répondriez-vous ?
RB : Je pense que chacun -
les gens font des choses pour des tas de raisons différentes
et je pense que, quand je serai sur mon lit de mort
je voudrais avoir l'impression que j'ai apporté quelque chose
dans la vie des autres.
C'est peut-être une pensée égoïste,
mais c'est la manière dont j'ai été élevé.
Je pense que si j'ai la capacité de
changer radicalement la vie d'autres en mieux,
je dois le faire.
CA : Quel âge avez-vous ?
RB : J'ai 56 ans.
CA : Le psychologue Erik Erikson dit que, tel que je le comprends
et je suis un amateur total, mais à 30, 40 ans les gens sont poussés par
le désir de grandir et c'est là qu'ils trouvent leur accomplissement,
à 50, 60 ans le mode opératoire change vers la quête de la sagesse
et la recherche de l'héritage.
Il semble que vous êtes encore
un petit peu dans la phase de croissance,
vous êtes encore en train de faire ces nouveaux plans incroyables.
Combien pensez-vous à l'héritage,
et qu'aimeriez-vous que soit votre héritage ?
RB : Je ne pense pas que je pense beaucoup à l'héritage.
J'aimerais - ma grand-mère a vécu jusqu'à 101 ans,
aussi espérons qu'il me reste encore 30 ou 40 ans à vivre.
Non, je veux juste vivre la vie à son maximum.
Si je peux changer quelque chose,
j'espère être capable de le faire.
Je pense qu'une des choses positives en ce moment est
que vous avez Sergey et Larry de Google, par exemple,
qui sont de bons amis.
Et, Dieu merci, vous avez deux personnes
qui sincèrement se préoccupent du monde et avec ce genre de fortune.
S'ils avaient ce genre de fortune et ne se préoccupaient pas du monde,
ce serait très inquiétant.
Ils vont faire de sacrées choses pour le monde.
Je pense que c'est important
que les gens dans ce genre de position fassent vraiment quelque chose.
CA : Eh bien, Richard, quand j'ai commencé dans le monde des affaires
je n'en savais rien et j'étais aussi un peu -
je pensais que les hommes d'affaires devaient juste être impitoyables
et que c'était le seul moyen pour avoir une chance de réussir.
En fait, vous m'avez inspiré. Je vous ai regardé, j'ai pensé,
eh bien, il l'a fait, peut-être il y a un autre moyen.
Aussi je voudrais vous remercier pour cette inspiration
et pour être venu à TED aujourd'hui. Merci.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)